Від традиційних лінійок з піснями і танцями - до захоплюючих квестів.
Українська шкільна освіта багато в чому все ще не може визначитися між минулим і майбутнім.
Однак є люди, які щодня змінюють заскорузлу освітянську систему.
Ще три роки тому Олена Бондаренко і Альона Парфьонова не знали одна про одну.
Нині ж засновниці  громадського об'єднання "БАТЬКИ SOS" спільно вирішують багато проблем.
Почалася їхня співпраця в часи Євромайдану.
Тоді з батьківського фонду освітнього закладу, де навчається син Альони, зникли понад 170 тисяч гривень.
Дирекція школи, в яку ходить дитина Олени, пішла ще далі.
В нашій школі є тренажерний зал, який використовується директором і його друзями.
Це обурило мам. Тож вони подали заяву про виявлені зловживання в міліцію.
Зрештою домоглися зняття директорів шкіл з посад.
Створили у "Фейсбуці" сторінку "БАТЬКИ SOS", де про подібні порушення могли би писати й інші.
Відтоді до сторінки приєдналося понад 30 тисяч користувачів.
Тепер "БАТЬКИ SOS" не лише викривають фінансові махінації через шкільні благодійні фонди,
а й навчають робити це багатьох батьків у інших містах України.
Крім того, дають імпульси для реформи усієї системи освіти.
Реформи роблять люди, які на місцях працюють. А у нас з цим велика проблема.
Ми навіть на етапі рекомендацій від МОНу минулого року запровадили зелену ручку замість червоної.
Воно не виконується.
Тож "БАТЬКИSOS"ініціювали конкурсний набір на посади директорів шкіл у Києві.
Миїдемо в одну з таких шкіл, аби побачити реформу в дії.
О,  вже спортивний зал відремонтований… Бачиш, Оленко, вже вікна є...
Андрій Мельник, вчитель історії і права, став директором у січні 2016-го.
Нові пластикові вікна – не єдине, чим може похвалитись.
В школу, де був недобір, почали приходити нові учні.
Ідей, як зробити навчання цікавим -  чимало.
От тільки замість того, щоб їх втілювати, амбітний директор застрягає у бюрократії освітньої системи.
Дати звіт, фотозвіт... Що піде в район, в  місто, в міністерство і ще куди...
І саме головне, що це стане просто тисячним файлом.
Зазвичай на вході охорону виставляють і не пускають.
Очільниць "Батьків SOS" так прихильно вітають рідко.
Адже приходять переважно туди, де є проблеми.
Активістки певні: якісних реформ досягнути легше у співпраці - між батьками, директорами і міністерством.
Нині обговорюють новий "Закон про освіту".
Зараз виходить, півтори тисячі правок внесли, а вони не можуть порівняльну таблицю скласти.
Розумієш, півтори тисячі правок. І що залишиться від закону?
Правки вносять і "Батьки SOS"
Активістки входять до складу колегії Міністерства освіти і просувають, зокрема,
закріплення концепції конкурсного добору директорів на законодавчому рівні.
Тож, можливо, час йти в політику?
З усмішкою кажуть: без підтримки загалу і там нічого не вирішити.
У планах натомість продовжити через громадську активність тиснути на владу.
А ще - податись на грант.
Адже наразі об'єднання існує винятково за рахунок ініціативи двох мам.
І якщо Альона для сімейного бізнесу час ще знаходить, то журналістка Олена повністю занурилася в громадську діяльність.
Добре, каже, що родина розуміє її вибір.